[Music]
Selena Gomez makes it a girls night at
the 2018 Met Gala Oh truth the 25 year
old singer hit the steps at New York's
Metropolitan Museum of Art on Monday
sans date instead making the night all
about reuniting with old pals look good
good for you Oh Selena totally embodied
this year's theme posing it up in a
heavenly sheer coach gown which
according to the design house drew
inspiration from the fall 2018
collection to create the brunette
beauty's look toughness mixed with dark
romantic femininity I wanted it to kind
of capture Queen Esther in the Bible I
admire her strength and I think that's
what I wanted it to feel like off the
carpet Selena was spotted hugging model
and fellow Taylor Swift squad member
Gigi Hadid both girls hit the event solo
and seemed genuinely happy to catch up
of course last year Gomez attended the
gala with then-boyfriend The Weeknd who
previously dated and attended fashions
biggest night with Gigi's younger sister
Bella Gomez also reunited with Kylie
Jenner for this adorable photo the
former friends haven't been photographed
together in years